[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
le samedi soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous ne connaissez pas ces types voici
les bratislavent
em
les bras tissent la boys mesdames
messieurs pour la première fois sur un
plateau de télévision en France fort
Jack Piot et Olaf worak vorac tous les
trois marins de profession ils se sont
rencontrés en 1975 dans un bar karaoké
de danse en Pologne ils ne se sont plus
jamais quittés il faut dire qu'ils
étaient loin d'imaginer l'incroyable
aventure qui les attendaient traduction
[Musique]
donc 600 millions d'albums vendus
26 fois lauréat 26 fois lauréat des
stars
[Applaudissements]
ici l'album plus la porte
[Musique]
donc ce sont des stars énormes dans leur
pays j'imagine non
ils ont la chance de se rencontrer parce
que ils auraient pu mourir de faim quand
ils étaient enfants mais à 6 ans ils ont
eu la chance de travailler dans les
mines des charbon qui a au slovaquista
c'est l'amour qui passe dire boutique
mon cul veut dire qu'ils ont été obligés
de se prostituer pour pour vivre là-bas
et alors bon là comment ils ont trouvé
la France vous pouvez leur demander
France
j'aime beaucoup le Michel Foucault
et donc là donc ils sont en France pour
combien de temps
vous avez pas envie de voir d'autres
pays l'Angleterre l'Amérique la Hollande
il faut que je leur dise
et donc est-ce qu'il pourrait nous
interpréter leur chanson qui s'appelle
statch
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coucou coucou coucou
[Musique]
en exclusivité
merci merci au Bratisla Boys d'avoir
choisi tout le monde en parle merci
beaucoup
mais moi j'ai pas y avoir
mais moi je suis tranquille va y avoir
wesh ma gueule
bonsoir bonsoir Thierry c'était pas mal
ce groupe qui avait avant là
il y a un message qui est assez positif
puisque ça parle de Liberta et Liberta
en slovaquistanais ça veut dire
réfrigérateur
un réfrigérateur pour tous qui est quand
même aujourd'hui très joli
vous êtes devenu rapidement une des
vedettes de la télévision française
Skyrock après Fun TV et M6 voilà et
après et après il y a ça
[Applaudissements]
qui s'est habillé en smoking pour la
circonstance
[Applaudissements]
et qui nous fait une entrée à provisée
[Musique]
qui n'est pas du tout trop longue
je suis désolé ça va paraître un petit
peu prétentieux mais il n'y a qu'un seul
vainqueur à cette soirée des 7 d'or
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
voilà les secteurs
musicales bravo
la grande question qu'on me pose arrêtez
oh c'est bon
la grande question qu'on me pose
toujours
faites attention je fais du jet Jugi Dao
là la grande question qu'on peut sourire
c'est pourquoi vous montrez vos fesses
tirez vous la posez pas cette question
non moi
je réponds
plus souvent c'est pas ce que j'ai un
beau cul tout simplement Siri elles sont
elles sont comment vos fesses la
franchement jamais j'y arriverai ça vous
savez dans l'émission sauf si on est
tous les deux mais là il y a on est que
tous les deux Thierry allez ce qu'on va
faire
ce qu'on va faire si je vous aide on va
non non allez chérie
Ardisson est-il un menteur d'ici la fin
de l'émission non alors à la fin de
l'émission mais mais pas mais pas quand
c'est coupé
Catherine Barma est pas d'accord non
mais Catherine Barma c'est bon je fais
mon affaire elle est très Chanel
aujourd'hui je t'embrasse Catherine tu
es super festival
par exemple
[Musique]
c'est un vrai public de télévision
donc c'est moi je croyais que c'était du
bidon
avec plaisir c'est du placo ça c'est du
polystyrène ouais fais attention
la moquette on voit là encore le
chatterton c'est tu es content d'être là
bah écoute tu me fais faire le tour du
propriétaire pendant que la caméraman
qui décède
alors tout ça c'est à toi c'est un peu à
moi ouais ouais
derrière la caméra il y a Françoise dit
bonjour à François salut Françoise ah
François je fais pas ta [__] demande ton
visage
c'est super bon
Nicolas je veux demander à mon caméraman
de venir aussi j'ai toujours un
cameraman qui me suit dans ma vie pour
pour pas que après j'oublie
ça c'est Laurence ah bah oui c'est la
rédactrice en chef de l'émission vas-y
c'est payé on embrasse sur la bouche
partout
avec la langue je mets les doigts tout
ça
sera peut-être plus facile avec Valérie
mamieuse
pas franchement en plus j'ai pas pris
des capotes
ça c'est l'Ange Blanc tu peux te la
faire aussi c'était la vie mais attends
mais en fait c'est une énorme partouze
après l'émission
Ça c'est la poubelle voilà non c'est de
la courbe dedans c'est que de la coque
des saladier de coque entier et ça c'est
le buffet tu vois regarde regarde
comment bouffe bien regarde oh la vache
c'est bien parce que tous les deux on
est pas très grand et à la télé on fait
plus grand et là c'est pratique parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on fait un 96
tous les deux
quand les gens me voient en vrai il est
plus petit c'est pour ça
hein merci le linge blanc c'est ça c'est
malin je regarde regarde ils sont dessus
alors Mesdames et Messieurs c'est une
avant-première pour la première fois la
loge de tirer Ardisson oh là là
qu'est-ce que tu fous là je t'avais dit
c'est pas vrai avec des petites coquines
bon je leur fais répéter le blind test
vous le savez il y a une tradition dans
cette émission c'est qu'à la fin de
chaque émission il y a le blind test
présenté par Monsieur Philippe Corti
ouais rock n' roll ce soir
d'accord
et que c'est une personne tellement loin
alors là on continue la visite je vais
te présenter un ami à moi ah je
connaissais pas du tout que j'ai
découvert qu'un mec vachement sympa tu
l'a découvert normalement c'est
extrêmement quand il est venu faire
l'émission
C'est un type extraordinaire je vais te
donner à l'indice
tu sors de chez toi alors c'est qui je
vais te donner un indice c'est le mec
qui a écrit une chanson très connue une
chanson qu'on adore et tu vas voir on va
le voir il est là tu vas voir là c'est
le studio sur le travail tout le monde
fait ses émissions ici attends là on est
sur on est sur un autre plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1 2 3 ouais ça marche pas
il y a un mec qui était dans ton école
là
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous inquiéter
nous allons faire maintenant
l'interview nul on ne bouge pas pendant
le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
interview nul vous êtes prêts
est-ce que vous préférez votre père ou
votre mère
je préfère Noël ma mère
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous préférez Hitler ou
Staline à Staline
en plus donc je pense que le mec est
plus fort d'accord alors vous partez 3
ans dans un vaisseau spatial 3 ans c'est
long déjà j'y vais pas bon c'est long 3
ans vous avez le choix entre trois
personnes Thomas Valentin le directeur
des programmes de M6 Dominique Farrugia
le directeur des programmes de Canal+ où
Étienne Moujotte je réfléchis même pas
Étienne moujat ah ouais on doit bien se
marrer avec lui
est-ce que vous préfériez faire l'amour
avec une fille très laide ou un mec très
beau mais en général je préfère tout
simplement faire l'amour avec avec ceux
ou celles qui veulent quoi d'accord oui
sans que je sois obligé de les forcer
parce que moi j'aime pas taper et
je suis obligé
bien
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que vous préférez incarner en
bataille ou en fontaine alors attention
un indice ne s'affiche pas sur votre
écran
ni l'un ni l'autre bravo
c'est pas une réponse c'était évidemment
la bonne réponse non mais applaudissez
pas vous rendez compte que vous
applaudissez n'importe quoi
c'est comme ça vous allez me faire la
poudre
[Musique]
Patrick Bruel
ils ont fait des progrès alors un ami
débarque chez vous à l'improviste
ce qui vous gêne le plus qu'il trouve
sur votre table de nuit Minecraft oui
les froyables un peu dur de Thierry
Messon
ou un godemichet alors sans hésiter
Thierry messanc parce que je dois vous
dire que je l'ai regardé dans votre
émission Thierry et j'ai fait oh [__]
mais donc mais toutes les immenses
supercheries et ça se trouve super en
sécurité et après je l'ai vu dans
d'autres émissions de télé se faire
démonter la gueule et je me suis aperçu
donc cet homme qui avait l'air ma foi
assez gentil était peut-être à un petit
peu fanfreluche donc
Thierry mais ça va me répondre merci
si vous aviez un perroquet
vous lui apprendrez
tu as fermé le gaz
vous dites ça parce que je suis
d'origine juive
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
la coco
je vais dire je vais dire ta pensée à
éteindre le gaz parce que chez moi c'est
des plaques électriques donc je m'en
fous voilà alors vous préfériez mourir
comme
Otis Redding dans un crash d'avion John
Lennon tué à bout portant Claude
François dans une baignoire avec un je
sais pas quoi John Bonham le batteur de
Led Zep étouffé dans son vomi ou Janis
Joplin par overdose
oh là là quel programme vous êtes une
star faut apprendre à mourir comme une
star mais je préférais mourir comme
comme Patrick Roy on en parle pas assez
de Patrick
non comme Philippe Dedieu le veut dans
l'incertitude la plus totale
c'est guest cette émission
il est mort
est-ce qu'on fait
salut merci c'était super j'ai adoré
Michael
[Musique]
non je vais rester
est-ce que vous préférez avoir
un nez supplémentaire un
œil supplémentaire à un doigt
supplémentaire
pourquoi pourquoi parce que je vais vous
dire la vérité
le jour de la distribution des bits
malheureusement dans la file d'attente
j'étais à la fin et donc j'ai eu un j'en
ai une de merde
vous connaissez ce type voici Franck
Dubosc
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir alors récemment la
presse parlait d'une année du boss oui
tout à fait une année du buzz donc
comment on l'a dit il y a effectivement
sur France 2 On a tout essayé avec
Laurent Ruquier il y a Europe 1 aussi
l'émission de Laurent Ruquier On va se
gêner
il y a votre spectacle je vous ai pas
raconté la tournée dans toute la France
de ce spectacle preuve
ultime de votre statitude Franck Dubosc
vous avez été gaulé par voici par le
magazine Voici avec votre ami Sabrina
c'est le comble là c'est maintenant moi
je l'ai su en fait je lis pas voici sauf
quand je suis dedans donc c'est rarement
et on m'a appelé pour me dire tu as vu
tel que avec Sabrina dans Voici enfin on
m'a dit tu es avec ta femme j'ai dit
laquelle
on me dit Sabrina
et voilà
ils ont été gentils oui ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'ils ont réussi à
prendre des photos de moi avec une
casquette et des lunettes de soleil très
très star américaine ça moi quand je
vois des stars américaines en photo dans
Voici ils ont toujours la casquette et
les lunettes de soleil
et un gros bide voilà là le gros bide je
l'avais mais le voyez pas la casquette
américaine c'est la seule journée de ma
vie où je l'ai porté ils ont réussi à me
prendre en photo je suis sûr que le
rédacteur en chef a dit attendez qu'il
porte une casquette américaine
[Applaudissements]
alors on va regarder un extrait du
spectacle bonjour
je suppose que tu es
le sait
je suis Franck Dubosc
si je peux me permettre Lucie j'aime
beaucoup la la texture de tes collants
comment ce sont des bas
tu veux dire avec les petites bretelles
et tous les trucs là
tu vas Véronique que ça fait pas
forcément [__]
d'apporter tes valises lui si attends
Véronique ça va on a de malheureux quand
même les prendre mince en plus toi tu
risques pas défiler ton jogging
je suis rentré chez moi sans faire de
bruit
Véronique dormez
elle était allongé sur le lit c'est pour
toi
ne soyez pas jaloux les filles ça va
plutôt bien sur n'importe qui d'autre
mais sur toi peut-être
sur toi non pas sur toi
j'ai pas pouvoir [__] tout le monde
non plus
donc je dis donc je suis rentré sans
faire de bruit Véronique dormez elle
était allongée sur le lit entièrement
nue
à côté d'un vietnamien
enlacer dans les bras d'un grand black
entièrement nul lui aussi
j'ai pris une photo je l'ai envoyé à
Benetton c'est jamais
et donc si vous voulez ils ont tiré les
équipes au sort et moi veinard je suis
tombé sur Sandy mais attention au début
je savais pas qui c'était moi on me dit
Franck tu partages ton canoë avec ça
on est que tous les deux ah ouais pas
plus de 200 kg par canoë
Franck Dubosc la messieurs le DVD la
cassette de son spectacle je vous ai pas
raconté en tournée dans toute la France
bravo
c'est vraiment l'année du boss je crois
que c'est vrai toi en France en Belgique
et en Suisse aussi parce que ils sont
vraiment géniaux ils me reçoivent comme
si j'étais de chez eux dis donc alors
que je m'en fous complètement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
interview alerte rose Franck Dubosc
bonjour madame
Elisa parce que Sabrina pas loin là il
valide
Franck quel est le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte
dans ma loge après l'émission non je
sais pas moi le mon lieu idéal
ce serait entre deux voitures mal garées
mais avec une contractuelle
quel est l'endroit où vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour Franck
avec une contractuelle
en public
du tout du tout c'est décidément votre
question Thierry c'est non non non je
suis désolé non non c'est pour ça qu'on
sort peu ensemble c'est vrai c'est vrai
quand c'est fini
dès qu'il a un peu chaud
[Musique]
vous préférez draguer ou vous faire
draguer me faire draguer
est-ce que vous préférez larguer ou
faire larguer
moi je suis un garçon je suis donc un
peu lâche donc je préfère me faire
larguer les filles ont fait plus où
vous préférez embrasser ou faire
embrasser quand vous dites ça Thierry
j'ai déjà entendu cette question que
vous faites c'est de vous vous pensez
[__] ou vous faire [__]
alors je préfère embrasser parce que se
faire embrasser ça doit faire très mal
et ouais
est-ce que vous préférez caresser ou
vous faire caresser
c'est dur de les avoir à côté parce que
je me dis c'est exprès
j'ai peur qu'elle me caresse c'est très
possible ce genre de la maison France
donc je préfère me faire caresser
d'accord Sabrina
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer écouter moi j'estime Thierry que
l'amour c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait avec quelqu'un qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps quelqu'un qu'on aime je veux
dire on a il faut qu'il y a besoin d'une
rencontre de parler de
de se connaître d'avoir quelque chose
qui
qui je crois que je pourrais baiser le
premier soir
[Musique]
vous préférez une femme qui baise bien
mais qui était infidèle ou une femme qui
baise mal mais qui est fidèle France si
c'est pas la mienne je préfère une femme
qui baise bien qu'un fidèle
si votre partenaire vous propose une
partie à trois vous préférez que ça soit
un homme ou une femme
mais avec un homme j'aurais trop peur de
me faire embrasser
vous préféreriez que votre femme vous
quitte pour un homme ou pour une femme
pour une femme mais pas avec ma
maîtresse
vous préféreriez que votre femme
couche avec un autre en pensant à vous
ou couche avec vous en pensant à un
autre pour ma femme ne pense pas Thierry
[Applaudissements]
je plaisante Sabrina il plaisante
en pensant à vous coucher avec moi
pensez à moi
en amour vous êtes partisans de tout se
dire ou de rien savoir
rien savoir oh non tout se dire
j'en parle justement moi dans mon
spectacle qu'est-ce que tu alors chérie
tu as fait l'amour cet après-midi génial
raconte qu'est-ce qu'il t'a fait
qu'est-ce qu'ils t'ont fait ah bah dis
non non non je dois les couples libérés
c'est pas pour vous n'êtes pas couper le
libérer du tout du tout du tout
je suis je ne suis pas jaloux vous savez
où elle est là
sincèrement tout de suite je m'en fous
un peu
alors
vous préféreriez faire l'amour à 1000
femmes toujours de la même façon ou à
une femme de mille façons différentes je
savais pas qu'il y avait 1000 façons
mais
à 1000 femmes d'une façon
parce que chaque femme est différente
donc ce sera jamais pareil
[Musique]
c'est assez tentant c'est vrai
vous préfériez une femme qu'on prend
sans la comprendre ou qu'on comprend
sans la prendre si je pouvais faire
baiser avec Amélie Nothomb on fait les
Winter
je préférerais non je préfère une femme
que je ne prends pas et que je comprends
ah ouais c'est beau ça c'est pour ça que
je le dis sinon la vérité c'est l'autre
il faudrait faire l'interview focus
vous préférez que la lumière soit
éteinte allumée Franck
moi je fais l'amour tellement longtemps
que bien évidemment si elle est allumée
que c'est moi qui paye l'électricité
ok interview focus je préfère la lumière
allumée pour pouvoir voir ma partenaire
bien entendu dans les yeux enfin dans
les yeux
dernière question est-ce que vous l'avez
déjà fait dans l'eau oui ou en vacances
en la Méditerranée mais le sable le sel
dans la mer ça irrite les femmes et donc
on n'a pas fait trop trop longtemps quoi
ce qui m'arrange
[Musique]
santé
encaissette et DVD en tournant toute la
France en Suisse en Belgique
non il faut une petite
brune
d'ailleurs je n'aime que l'été car
celle-là et toi très flash je te love
c'est ça qu'il faut une grosse avec des
cheveux courts mais bien sûr depuis tout
petit je kiffe sur des grosses laver les
cheveux courts
le chanteur et le parolier c'est Pierre
Palma il est là mesdames messieurs
bienvenue n'aime que les petits points
car celle-là et toi tu te flash je te
lave je te place
musique de Jean-Michel Jarre paroles de
Pierre Palmas
ça va ça s'est bien passé avant
bien sûr ça va très bien donc l'émission
non plus
mais il arrive du théâtre
pour ceux qui pensent que l'émission est
pas en direct il arrive du théâtre merci
pour l'enchaînement donc au théâtre ils
se sont aimés de mûrir
je l'adore cette Michel Laroque donc la
pièce effectivement était écrite par
Muriel Robin et Pierre Palmade et les
jouets par Pierre Palmade et la
merveilleuse Michel Laroque gros gros
succès ouais ça va les gens viennent ils
nous ont aimé de la première expérience
c'est parfait
que c'était en France le seul truc qui
était de qualité zeinfeld voilà donc ça
c'est important
voilà et puis après il y a un petit peu
de tournée non
vous allez jouer ça au zénith il y a un
Zénith dans une configuration humaine on
va faire 3000 personnes très très près
de la Seine mais un Zénith parce que pas
parce que les gens sont d'accord pour
alors
pierre et Jean-Michel vous avez pas mal
de choses en commun finalement tous les
deux en dehors du cinéma
alors le père absent en commun
c'est-à-dire que vous bon l'a dit votre
père est parti aux États-Unis vous aviez
5 ans Pierre malheureusement encore plus
triste il est parti
j'en profite pour dire bonjour à mon
père si nous regarde parce que TV5
effectivement il y a 80 pays qui
regardent cette émission donc je le
salue bon voilà à tout hasard à tout
hasard c'est pas peut-être qu'il va vous
appeler et donc vous faudrait que ça
passe au paradis
mais c'est déjà une chose en commun
c'est cette absence de père vous
effectivement il est décédé quand parler
mais ça se sent sans confiance
malheureusement et donc très proche tous
les deux de vos mères aussi finalement
et réciproquement sont très
beaucoup de points communs donc le père
absent élevé par des mers et aussi vous
avez choisi tous les deux des femmes
femmes vous Charlotte vous Véronique
Sanson ça aussi c'est quelque chose qui
vous rapproche vous êtes déjà parlé non
c'est une amitié
il y a des choses qu'on a pas besoin de
se dire en fait finalement c'est c'est
vous qui nous le dites et on va s'en
parler certainement après l'émission
bien Jean-Michel je vais vous faire à
tous les deux une interview nulle
on ne bouge pas pendant le bouge pas
pendant le jingle
alors allons-y Pierre Palmade ça tombe
sur vous vous devez partir dans un
vaisseau spatial pendant trois ans
est-ce que vous préférez partir avec
Elisabeth Tessier madame de Fontenay ou
Nadine de Rothschild
dans les étoiles dont je la trouvais que
je l'aime qui d'autre madame de Fontenay
Miss France ou Nadine de Rothschild
je sais pas celle que je connais pas je
vais prendre Nadine Nadine alors
Jean-Michel Jarre si vous aviez le choix
vous préfériez faire l'amour avec une
fille très laide ou avec un mec très
beau
avec les deux peut-être ou peut-être
ouais peut-être ouais il faut voir c'est
difficile ça dépend ça dépend de la
laideur et de la beauté ça dépend ce
qu'on appelle c'est très subjectif
au pire Balma nous a dispensé de
questions c'est à vous maintenant le mot
le plus con en amour
c'est merci encore ou oui oui
le mot le plus con en amour merci le
plus con je vais te dire c'est quelqu'un
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a reconnu pendant
les rapports allez
la personne était un peu embrumée moi
aussi et c'est pendant les rapports la
personne a ouvert les yeux a fait oh
pure vole même
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Michel est-ce que vous savez vous
lécher la langue
[Rires]
ah mais si si on peut on peut bien
il faut céder du palais ouais non pas le
vous lécher la moustache
c'est ça le service public bien
attention Palmade nous sommes seuls qui
tous les deux vous et moi d'accord
bloquez l'hiver dans un chalet il fait
très très froid il y a 3 mètres de neige
on a rien à bouffer je meurs de froid
vous mourrez de faim vous me mangez vous
commencez par quoi
on a une bonne tranche de un beau
cuisseau un beau cuissot de d'Ardisson
et vous genre le bas des oreilles c'est
pas mal
d'où ça pour commencer pas mal mais on
commence pas
comment gentil
avec plaisir
Jean-Michel vous préfériez être
réincarné en slip de François Hollande
je sais de François Bayrou ou de Nicolas
Sarkozy
ça c'est très très dur ça fait quel est
le plus propre à ton avis
voulait être incarné est-ce que vous
savez que vous serez réincarné en slip
je suicide ah ouais
je me suicide avant avant
apparemment quand on suicide on est pas
incarné bon alors et vous Pierre Palmade
vous préféreriez être incarné en slip de
François Hollande de François Bayrou ou
de Nicolas Sarkozy
savoir quel est le plus propre
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est celle que je
connais donc
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Michel Jarre ça tombe sur vous
d'accord vous préfériez mourir comme
Otis Redding dans un crash d'avion John
Lennon un shot à bout portant Janis
Joplin une Audi une overdose ou comme
John Bonham le batteur de Led Zep qui
est mort étouffé dans son vomi ça c'est
pas une question nul sauf le dernier cas
je dirais John Lennon
je supporte pas et une idée c'est pas
terrible si vous étiez en vente dans un
sexe shop vous seriez quoi je sais pas
ben non quoi
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Michel vous seriez quoi vous étiez
en vente dans un sex-shop un mode
d'emploi
vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaire un œil supplémentaire un
doigt supplémentaire ou alors quoi un
sexe
supplémentaire
ça fait un peu monstre tandis qu'un sexe
Jean-Michel un sexe d'homme en plus ou
un sexe de femme ah bonne question
ça serait pas mal d'avoir un sexe c'est
pas mal non plus les deux ouais les deux
moi j'ai déjà les deux
[Applaudissements]
on m'appelle l'enceinte
[Musique]
je vous demande de vous étirer
franchement on t'aime bien mais là tu
exagère
je vous demande de vous arrêter
je demande de vous arrêter
et qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
on m'appelle
voilà
merci Didier bravo
bravo merci Didier tu nous as arrêté
il faut que Jean-Michel Jarre Vienne
pour qu'elle décolle
merci merci le groupe de recherche
musicale merci Pierre Schaeffer et
maintenant
[Musique]
c'est bien
faisez tous comme moi
avec la carillon voici à la Chabat et
Gérard Darmon
je vous demande de vous arrêter
je vous demande de vous arrêter ah merci
beaucoup je vous demande de vous arrêter
toi aussi arrête-toi maintenant ça
suffit là alors
Alain Chabat Gérard Darmon vous êtes ici
pour la sortie du film
Astérix mais en fait vous avez pas
besoin de promotion ce film va faire un
carton intégral si ça vous avez eu les
chiffres et tout tout est bon tout est
bon
merci
tellement je suis rassuré
pour les comédies en général il y en a
pas et puis
donc 11 pour darmonck est quand même
incroyable dans le film c'est ce qui
explique ma venue ici et ton costume on
va parler de tout ça
bon alors comment ça va ça va bien alors
Astérix et Obélix mission Cléopâtre donc
c'est votre nouveau film avec vous au
Gérard Darmand et une pléiade de belette
non ce qui est génial quand même c'est
d'arriver à faire un film de potes à 50
millions d'euros quoi c'est sympathique
je dis pour les gens c'est 350 millions
de francs quand même
et le prix de la place reste le même
le premier avait fait 9 millions
d'entrée vous allez en faire 15 à peu
près non je sais pas c'était quoi les
chiffres 16 millions sur Paris
premier jour
parce que génial c'est que c'est un film
de potes à 50 millions d'euros et puis
que c'est aussi un arabe qui est star
dans un film de Gaulois quoi
il y a des martiens et des Maltais il y
a des Marocains et des il y a plein de
[__] dans le film c'est comment on
fait les enfants tu sais toi
tu pourrais le faire pour ton poste
[Musique]
ce ne sont pas les Romains qui ont
construit les pyramides
des trucs pointus
je vais lui construire les plus
magnifiques des palais et c'est toi
numéro bis qui ne sera l'architecte
c'est-à-dire tu as trois mois jour pour
jour top chrono
avec combien de temps de retard
il me faut des pouvoirs magiques
[Musique]
Astérix
le petit gaulois un nom de héros
[Musique]
de 30 janvier
c'est génial le balai sur I feel good là
c'est énorme alors quand Berry vous a
proposé Claude Berry vous a proposé vous
avez fait un peu votre chose shot au
début vous dites mais comment vous savez
tout ça
est-ce que je peux vous le faire à
chaque question
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci les enfants je vous demande de
vous arrêter voilà vous avez fait un peu
la chochotte non c'est vrai pourquoi
parce que j'étais en train d'écrire un
scénario que je pensais bon qui était
pas bon et donc j'ai dit non je suis en
train d'écrire un truc donc non j'ai pas
envie de faire Astérix
la première ambition d'Alain Chabat
quand il vivait à Massy
Alain Chabat le petit pied-noir exilé
rêver d'être Walt Disney
alors
c'est vrai non vous êtes branché bande
dessinée depuis toujours je voulais être
successeur de Walt Disney quand j'étais
petit j'ai même mis ça sur profession
plus tard je crois au CM1
ça peut arriver parce que maintenant vu
le succès que vous avez vous connaissez
cats and Berg tous ces mecs là je
nettoie les plus grands
20 semaines de tournage quand même vous
êtes un vrai patron il paraît pas vous
êtes dirigé ça avec beaucoup de bon
toujours très perfectionniste évidemment
et beaucoup de calme
ça dépend des jours mais en général je
suis pas super nerveux mais c'est la
drogue beaucoup qui fait ça en parlant
drogue celui-là je le raconte quand même
il reste presque plus de potion magique
dans la petite fiole et Darmon qui fait
ça il prend mal
les gens racontent pas d'autres il y en
a plein alors oui non vous êtes
tellement calme et tout qui vous a plu
sur le tournage casse-couilles
tranquillix ah bon oui je savais pas
merci
c'est vrai ou c'est faux c'est vrai vous
aviez pas non sérieux
n'avez pas des fêtes tous les soirs
c'est une légende il faisait des fêtes
le en général le vendredi soir ou le
samedi soir samedi soir au Maroc
puisqu'on tournait six jours sur 7 le
samedi soir il y avait de toute façon
une teuf qui était organisée par où les
comédiens ou un comédiens ou les
costumes ou les décors etc
ou très souvent le mercredi le jeudi
tous les jeudis et puis après le
week-end vendredi samedi dimanche normal
moi j'ai raté tout ça moi j'allais à
celle du samedi soir vous êtes bien
mariés
un travail colossal c'est un travail
colossal de faire un film il a bossé
incroyable donc toute façon il est il
est né pour ça
viable
avec l'impression toujours de faire un
court-métrage quoi c'est ça qui est
incroyable alors vous en fait un jour
vous dîner avec votre ami Vincent Lindon
et Vincent vous dit tu sais que shabbat
prépare son Astérix et je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'étais dans ma bulle entre
autres j'étais dans ma bulle ouais
j'étais un peu j'étais un peu hassé une
époque j'étais
pas trop bien ça arrive dans la vie
pourquoi c'était quoi alors je vais
t'expliquer
chagrin d'amour Gérard exactement j'ai
été sûr pas toujours non mais c'est un
sentimental d'argent alors vous appelez
Alain Chabat vous lui dites alors non je
dis pas alors je dis Alain je veux
prendre un petit café avec toi et il me
dit ok d'accord
je suis une sale période
cette période voilà je lui dis
j'aimerais bien faire partie de cette
aventure je sais pas quoi et très
franchement je dis toujours entre la fin
de ma question et sa réponse il s'est
passé quoi je sais pas une seconde et
demi quoi même pas il a dit je ne sais
pas dans quoi mais je suis d'accord
voilà
de l'appeler parce qu'autant je sais pas
aimer le film mais autant j'ai trouvé
Gérard formidable
c'était pas évident je trouve que
vraiment ils crèvent l'écran et il a
appréhendé ce rôle de méchant de façon
fantastique et je trouve qu'il
réhabilitent un peu le film et cette
débauche d'effets spéciaux c'est
dégueuler de fric à l'image
non ceci étant ceci étant c'est vrai que
votre personnage extraordinaire dans le
film c'est beaucoup d'humour de de vous
déguiser comme ça et surtout vous avez
inventé un personnage qui est le premier
reptile humain
et ça c'est vraiment ça c'est décidé la
veille du tournage ça oui c'est comme ça
c'est dans les dans les dans les affres
de l'acteur qui va qui va faire
ça veut dire ça en arabe
vous avez inventé ce truc du espèce de
rire sifflement comme ça oui je suis
tiens comment comment est-ce qu'il
risque perso ce mec il est bon c'est un
méchant pour moi un gros [__]
qu'est-ce qu'il doit bien rire bon donc
voilà j'ai trouvé
je suis obligé
mais c'est moins bien
[Musique]
là vous avez souffert parce que ce
tournage en plein désert 45 degrés des
fois 55 degrés 100 g et alors vous dites
les bijoux chauffés on a eu des fous de
chaleur on a eu des fou rire de chaleur
oui parce qu'on avait on avait la tête
pleine d'eau quoi on avait plus de
cerveau il devait faire à peu près 50 55
c'est fou 14 heures dans le désert à
Ouarzazate en plein mois de je ne sais
quoi il faisait 45 sous l'attente de
César
une équipe de cinéma les projets les
flambeaux c'était infernal et en plus
les les bougies et les bijoux étaient
voilà nous c'est tout c'est moche un bon
acteurs de chaleur et c'est vrai pendant
les prises je me brûlais les doigts en
simplement lui disant oh mon César et là
sur mon collier
le meilleur souvenir du tournage Alain
c'est quoi par le cacher là on parle
non mais c'est le franchement c'est le
tourne je suis super mauvais on anecdote
mais c'est vrai que c'est le tournage
c'est le l'humeur général de bon le
meilleur souvenir c'est le tournage le
plus mauvais souvenirs le plus mauvais
souvenir c'est le
c'est pas des mauvais souvenirs mais
c'est vrai que j'ai dirigé une ou deux
scènes des chiottes parce que je m'étais
pris une vraie bonne tourista et donc je
suis autoki dans les chiottes assis sur
le front même pas le moniteur de
contrôle il y a l'assistant qui fait ses
prêts tu veux vérifier je fais non c'est
bon ça les histoires
alors Alain Chabat et Gérard Darmon ce
film va être un énorme succès vous ne
m'en voudrez pas de vous faire une
interview
catastrophe
pendant le kingers on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
Alain Chabat
le jour même de votre mariage
vous avez le coup de foudre pour une
autre et c'est réciproque vous faites
quoi
c'est compliqué je suis très lâche
je dis oui mon amour
vous n'êtes pas à l'abri de la
catastrophe donc le jour du mariage coup
de foudre pour une autre c'est
réciproque vous faites quoi
je sais pas ça vous est déjà arrivé
peut-être en vrai
je vous remercie de m'aider
je sais pas je pense que moi j'aime bien
vivre les choses quand elles arrivent
alors je sais pas si c'est une chose qui
peut être faite immédiatement je le fais
je vois après si c'est vraiment un coup
de foudre d'accord
il change pas
alors vous êtes en vacances avec toute
votre famille
vous vous retrouvez seul avec votre
belle-mère qui vous fait des avances
c'est l'après-midi tout le monde est à
la mer vous êtes seul avec Mamie j'y
vais
et vous
moi c'est sans aucune hésitation j'y
vais aussi il y a aucun problème
votre femme vous annonce qu'elle a tous
les chiffres du Loto
mais vous avez oublié de valider le
bulletin ah ouais vous lui dites ça
comment
moi je dis gagner du temps c'est ça qui
est important
que tu as coché
tu comprends pourquoi on sait jamais
marié c'est tout alors vous allez
draguer une nana super vraiment super ça
c'est vrai je suis témoin
vous la ramenez chez vous
vous découvrez que c'est un travesti
vous réagissez comment pas arriver mais
je la refais
oui ça m'est arrivé bon j'y vais alors
pas de problème
il faut aimer les femmes avec des grands
clitoris moi je suis d'accord
c'est même un nom égyptien gros clitoris
donc ça reste dans la mission Cléopâtre
c'est la promo voilà c'est de la promo
papa ouais mon père pour moi il est je
suis toujours à l'école il me dit
comment ça va bien Claude Berry il est
content de ton travail car l'escure il
trouve que tu travailles bien non
mais c'est mon fan numéro 000 quand même
c'est lui que j'ai vu un Burger Quiz
exactement avec le père de farodjo
[Musique]
sur la route
pendant que les flics inspectent le
véhicule votre pote qui était assis à
côté de vous vous avoue qu'il transporte
un kilo de cocaïne dans son sac et vous
n'avez pas dit bien sûr faites quoi je
le couvre mais après on partage
ça c'est pas parce que comme ça dans la
réalité
[Musique]
j'ai pas compris vous êtes dans une
bagnole oui d'accord là je comprends
le pote avec qui vous êtes je suis aussi
au moment où les flics arrivent merde
j'ai un kilo de coupe dans le sac là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait vous faites quoi
vous je lui dis un gros con on va
essayer de s'en sortir mais c'est voilà
on essaie de de le passer ce et on le
jette après voilà
dans le nez
merci beaucoup votre fils vous annonce
qu'il va se marier à 4h30 ça
m'étonnerait
la jeune fille s'appelle Ben Laden vous
dites quoi vas-y nique là
pour sauver la population d'une ville là
vous êtes Bruce Willis pour sauver la
population d'une ville où je vais faire
sauter un train
sont à bord
faites quoi désolé pour la ville
et ça va pas être possible
[Musique]
vous partez en vacances à l'île Maurice
le 30 janvier dans un cinéma près de
chez vous mesdames messieurs
j'accueille maintenant Charlie et Lulu
bonsoir bonsoir à très bien et vous ça
va
vous êtes comme un couple qui dure tous
les deux non oui on va ça c'est le sexe
ça fait combien d'années le sexe moi
ensemble ça fait 10 ans c'est beaucoup
quand même et le hit cette saison lequel
a rencontré l'autre
chercher bien c'est celui qui m'a
rencontré forcément
il était près d'une camionnette à
Boulogne
Charlie vous feriez quoi si Lulu vous
avez pas rencontré qu'est-ce que je
ferais la télé
moi je serai riche
qu'est-ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
Charlie chez Charlie attention
[Applaudissements]
il faut être pile à l'heure enfin pour
lui être à l'heure c'est déjà trop tard
vous viviez ensemble tous les deux
lequel ferait la cuisine lui sûrement tu
m'as doudou hein
qu'est-ce qui ferait le ménage si vous
habitiez ensemble
qu'est-ce qu'il ferait la femme si vous
étiez ensemble je crois que c'est moi
non je crois que c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
vous aimez tous les deux vous aimez
France 2 oui je t'aime alors
lequel
[Applaudissements]
lequel est le plus drôle des deux noirs
de l'Académie à domicile quel message de
la chanson achetez-le parce que moi j'ai
un crédit au CIC pour la maison
[Musique]
c'est bien stop Orlando exige le clip
je m'appelle
et j'ai un bac moins 3
je suis prête à toucher
si ça peut me faire gagner
j'étais mise sous game
majorette Calais
je vais être super connu même s'il faut
montrer mon
[Musique]
on est
à toi de la cabinie
[Musique]
vraiment pas facile ouais j'en ai de la
messieurs
vous le faites très très bien bravo
moi non plus alors il y a ça aussi
Didier
[Musique]
je m'appelle Charlie et je m'appelle
Lulu on est sur M6 pour le Hit Machine
le samedi en campagne
[Musique]
sera trop bien à l'un de mes dents
on est
bien fait
manger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la totale pour la première fois ce soir
en continu j'avais lu dans
Champs-Élysées
bien
en tout cas musique et un super public
je vous demande de vous arrêter bien de
rien je vous demande de vous arrêter bon
alors Lulu oui vous avez déclaré dans
vital
en octobre 99 je ris de tout même de la
mort moi j'ai dit ça
qu'en est-il 3 ans plus tard ça dépend
de la mort de qui
Charlie
même numéro du même magazine vous avez
déclaré mon pire défaut c'est d'être
trop généreux parfois même je suis très
con ça c'est vrai
qu'en est-il aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
crois que je suis toujours aussi con
je crois que vous êtes mûr
pour une nouvelle interview qui
s'appelle quand je taperai dans mes
mains tu seras d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai très très peu
quand je taperai dans mes mains tu seras
le mime Marceau super énervé attention
pas Sophie Marceau
quand je tape après dans mes mains tu
seras un gagnant du loto attention
[Applaudissements]
quand j'étais après dans mes mains tu
seras un gagnant du loto qui a perdu le
ticket
oh non c'est pas possible
[Musique]
d'acteurs studio
Lulu quand je tape énormément tu seras
sérieux le killer
dans mes mains tu seras Benjamin
Castaldi
après les chansons les minions
attention quand je tape après dans mes
mains tu seras Dieu
oh là
je vous aime compris
quand je tape énormément tu seras
Charlie
[Applaudissements]
j'aime tout le monde
et je suis bien sur France 3 attention
quand j'étais après dans mes mains
Charlie tu seras Lulu ah ouais bon
de l'Académie à domicile
leur dernier opus
Lionel bonsoir bonsoir vous avez déclaré
Gad Elmaleh en ce moment je pourrais
aller à la télévision tous les jours
tellement j'ai de proposition mais je
refuse beaucoup de choses
je refuse de faire des vannes à la
chaîne ou de me mettre un poulet sur la
tête pour faire rire les gens on a un
poulet ouais hop
ça marche très bien voilà voilà ce que
voilà c'est quelqu'un de refuse de faire
donc c'est des vannes à la chaîne et se
mettre un poulet sur la tête c'est
dommage ça vous va très bien alors le
spectacle la vie normale c'est un gros
carton vous l'avez déjà joué 300 fois
mise en scène d'Isabelle Nanty et là
vous le jouez encore et c'est la fin là
c'est les dernières c'est les 30
dernières
ultime et irrévocable du 14 mai au 16
juin au Casino de Paris vous savez
comment on fait Gad
la main rotative la main rotative oui
donc voilà quoi après c'est fini il faut
y aller là oui il faut y aller parce
qu'après c'est fini ceux qui n'ont pas
on ça oui le DVD la cassette comment on
fait = ma rotative
[Musique]
ouais on peut voir ça comme ça
c'est vrai que quelques
il y a quelque part de deux écoles
[Musique]
allô oui bonjour est-ce que je pourrais
avoir le numéro de téléphone de France
de s'il vous plaît en France
[Musique]
voilà ensuite 4 photos d'identité format
A4
non non noir et blanc
voilà Monsieur dépense son argent à
valvolo Monsieur sachez des shampoings à
l'extrait d'acte de naissance
elle m'avait dit comme ça prochain
candidate c'est à VOUS Chocho joyeux
anniversaire
elle a dit comment appelle-t-on les gens
qui ne mangent pas la viande
alors moi j'ai dit les pauvres
tu la connais
merci
alors Gad Elmaleh ce sens de
l'autodérision de faire preuve de toute
façon éblouissante est venu très tôt
vous dites cette famille on avait un
regard décalé dans la famille et chez
vous on chariait beaucoup quoi c'est
beaucoup c'était culturel ça faisait
partie c'est déjà culturel dans l'absolu
mais dans ma famille c'était encore
c'était pire quoi ou moquez des gens qui
venaient les visiteurs qui viennent
chaque fois qu'il y avait des invités en
fait avec mon frère on se cachait on
faisait les dialogues on faisait des
espèces de doublage quoi d'accord on
faisait le mec qui parlait on ne partait
en vrille sur les discussions que
pouvait avoir mon père avec ces gens-là
est-ce que vous plaisez le plus quand
même c'était d'être le centre
d'attraction celui qu'on regarde sur
tout petit déjà voulu être au cœur de la
lumière avec les gens qui vous regardent
qui s'intéressent à vous quoi ce qui n'a
pas beaucoup changé non ce soir je suis
là pour vous regarder
faites-vous plaisir parce que à
n'importe quel moment je peux partir
parce que c'est sans rappel en plus
c'est irrévocable vous êtes né à
Casablanca dans une famille riche ni
pauvre en 67 quand la plupart des
familles juives quittent le Maroc votre
père choisit de rester pourquoi parce
qu'on y était bien et parce que bah
pourquoi les autres sont partis alors il
faut leur demander et ben ils sont là
justement
alors il y a un truc on vous dit
toujours et qui vous énerve vous avez
raison on dit votre père était mime
il savait faire du mime il avait fait du
mime mais il vivait pas du mime votre
père votre père il était agent
immobilier il était vendeur de sanitaire
il était gérant de magasin de jouets
dites-moi comment tu sais ça oh là là
voilà comment vous savez ça vous
merci merci voilà formidable ok ça c'est
un vrai public de télévision c'est vrai
bien dressé
il a été il a été mis il a vraiment fait
il a vraiment fait ça mais il a pas fait
très longtemps c'est tout mais oui il a
été mis d'où mes grands problèmes de
communication avec mon père
ça ça veut dire fais gaffe tu vas t'en
prendre une
rigolo il avait des cassettes de Pierre
Dax chez lui c'est vrai que Pierre Dax
si ça a aidé à votre culture c'est
formidable c'est génial j'adorais ça et
alors la maison ou parliez tous français
sauf dans les engueulades dans les
moments de passion là c'était l'arabe
qui reprenait le dessus quoi dans les
moments d'émotion quoi alors vous étiez
à l'école française l'école Georges
Bizet saviez pas d'ailleurs qui s'était
vraiment Georges Bizet à l'époque
maintenant aujourd'hui je sais que c'est
un footballeur
tellement l'école que vous avez fait
toutes les classes deux fois vous êtes
restés très longtemps comme ça tellement
ça vous plaisait
il y en a une que vous avez fait même
trois fois j'ai adoré la 6e j'ai la
sixième ça a été vraiment un moment pour
moi dans ma vie où année après année on
se revoyait c'était fou à partir quoi
alors bon vous avez quand même un petit
peu le complexe des fois de
l'autodidacte c'est-à-dire vous n'êtes
pas discipliné pour lire pour écrire
enfin vous avez quand même des problèmes
quand vous êtes pas allés à l'école
assez longtemps c'est dommage non c'est
pas un complexe c'est plus incomplexe en
fait parce que j'ai appris en fait j'ai
appris que la culture c'était autre
chose que la que la connaissance des
livres quoi j'y arrive pas à lire un
bouquin c'est très difficile pour moi
j'ai du mal à me concentrer vous savez
des fois même dans des scénarios de
films que je dois faire je je je lis et
puis je reviens trois pages en arrière
ça me prend à peu près trois semaines
voilà le film il est déjà fait ils ont
déjà pris un autre acteur moi j'appelle
je dis j'ai fini elle dit
[Applaudissements]
alors en 87 vous avez 16 ans et vous
partez au Québec et là c'est incroyable
c'est courage qui vous a fallu pour
quitter votre maman pour quitter le
Maroc pour quitter tout ça pour elle
parce que maman oui au Québec
ben là je pense que c'est ça qui
m'aurait tué vous savez que vous êtes
très regardé au Québec je suis le
français que les Québécois aiment
détester
alors là bon vous partez au Québec tant
pis pour vous vous laissez-nous tomber
moi je vivais à Casablanca au Maroc
j'avais fait le tour enfin le fait le
tour j'avais envie de bouger j'avais
envie de partir j'avais envie de
découvrir des choses et j'avais envie
d'aller en Amérique quoi je rêvais de ça
et puis il y avait déjà tombé non pas du
tout
pas du tout non non non
c'est pas comme Moïse qui est qui s'il
avait tourné un peu à droite on aurait
eu le pétrole non c'est pas la même
chose
[Applaudissements]
non c'est vrai qu'à force de regarder
les avions passé dans le ciel à Casa un
jour c'est monté dans un avion et il va
Montréal quoi voilà je l'ai choisi c'est
pas courageux c'est inconscient voilà
j'ai envie de dire ça voilà je crois que
c'est maintenant je crois qu'il faut
être sérieux et c'est le bon terme c'est
l'inconscient maintenant tu vas dire ça
tout le temps tout le temps là
vous faites la fac de sciences
politiques faut dire tout de suite c'est
beaucoup plus facile qu'en France c'est
pas du tout comme Sciences Po car là-bas
tout le monde peut le faire donc c'est
vrai non mais c'est vrai
je voulais je voulais rentrer en droit
et tous les mecs qui rentrent pardon ils
se retrouvent en sciences voilà si tu
veux à Paris quand tu fais Science Po
c'est que c'est top
c'est que tu as été accepté
alors rapidement quand même Gad Elmaleh
vous laissez tomber quand même la fac de
sciences politiques non
vous vire ce qui est quand même un
exploit ah oui ça c'est fort je savais
pas ça et alors là vous commencez à
faire des petites choses pour la radio
pour la télé dans des cabarets vous
décidez peu à peu de devenir une
vocation née à Montréal et vous prenez
conscience que pour vraiment devenir une
star il faut aller à Paris ouais enfin
je fais plein de petits boulots en
attendant notamment un petit boulot qui
m'a qui m'a traumatisé c'est que je
faisais dans un café à peu près 120
sandwichs de jambon surtout j'en ai
jamais mangé c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
des figurant dans la pièce je suis
rentré sur scène j'avais un truc à faire
dans cette pièce c'était je rentrais
avec un bougeoir au début c'est quand
même une performance aujourd'hui au
niveau de lactorat considérable ma mère
était en pleurs
quand il rentre avec ce bouge
comme tu es beau mon préféré c'est ça
franchement mais voilà et donc mais
sincèrement je croyais que j'étais au
tarte à ce moment-là alors à 96 vous
faites votre premier one man décalage
c'est un petit peu une façon justement
de combattre le cliché du jeune comédien
qui attend qu'on lui propose un long il
y a plutôt que d'attendre à côté du
téléphone vous dites je vais ça c'est
bien aussi ouais je vais bien décourager
ou inconscient mais c'est bien je crois
quelque part c'est ça
on peut parler de courage
et puis c'est parti bon ça marche
vachement bien spectacle très personnel
très personnel
alors que celui d'aujourd'hui est
beaucoup plus Universal
c'est comme ça tous les soirs voilà bon
après il y a décalage après il y a la
vie normale celui qui s'arrête là et
donc vous allez jouer 30 représentations
exceptionnelles
ultime et
puis alors vous avez raté ça c'est des
grands alors il est sympa il est beau
hein
[Musique]
ça me fait plaisir
alors garde
maintenant bon vous allez arrêter de
jouer la vie normale ça fera 330 fois ça
va bon il y a la cassette il y a le DVD
il y a tout bon vous allez faire quoi
moi je suis déjà en train de faire autre
chose
je suis déjà en train d'écrire un
prochain spectacle et je suis en train
d'essayer d'écrire un film voilà voilà
et chanter ça vous tente pas ouais moi
je vois très bien le chanteur oui je
j'aime ça vous chanter vachement bien je
crois que je chante assez bien vous
savez chanter
un truc un truc que vous savez chanter
bonsoir
je fais aussi les mariages les marmites
vannes les anniversaires
waouh
ok je connais pas les paroles mais je
vais faire du Springs d'accord ok on va
tous faire juste un petit un petit [__]
comme ça
i love you
[Musique]
c'est le vélo que Michel Drucker a donné
merci Gad pardon continue après pour les
paroles et voilà
et maintenant comme tout va bien on va
faire une interview cauchemar en app
[Applaudissements]
roche pas pendant le jingle
le pire des accidents conjugaux vous
faire surprendre par votre femme avec
votre maîtresse n'importe quoi
surprendre votre femme avec votre
meilleur ami
ou surprendre votre femme et votre
maîtresse ensemble
c'est surprendre ma femme avec mon
meilleur ami
c'est oui parce que j'en perds de d'un
coup
et là on dira pas le nom du meilleur ami
de la femme de Gad Elmaleh on dira juste
ça
c'était émission réputée pour sa
discrétion exactement donc on donne pas
les noms on donne que des indices alors
le pire cadeau qu'on puisse vous faire
une perceuse sans fil un abonnement un
club de gym huit jours de vacances avec
Vincent Perrot
un abonnement un club de gym parce que
déjà avec un seul abonnement je vous
croise dans les vestiaires c'est vrai
alors avec deux je craque
[Applaudissements]
la pire situation au quotidien avoir un
pétard mais pas de feu une carte bleue
mais pas le code une fille super mais
pas de préservatif une fille super mais
pas le feu
votre pire des illusions Gad Elmaleh ça
serait d'apprendre qu'il y a quelqu'un
dans quasimir
que Thierry la Fronde avait une
chaussette dans son collant
ou que Goldorak est doublé pour les
cascades que Goldorak est doublé pour
les cascades parce que ça c'est
dégueulasse
le pire ça serait d'apprendre que Dieu
n'existe pas ou qu'il existe mais que
c'est pas le vôtre
c'est que c'est que Dieu n'existe pas
parce que je pense pas que le Dieu que
en quel je crois parce que je crois en
Dieu soit que le mien mais c'est qu'il
n'existe pas parce qu'avec le nombre de
mecs qui se sont fait sauter en l'air et
qui ont tué des gens pour Dieu c'est pas
très sympa s'il existe le pire c'est de
grandir seul de vivre seul ou de mourir
seul de mourir seul parce que je l'ai
déjà vécu et je dois dire que c'est
assez dur ouais vraiment parce que de
grandir seul je l'ai fait vivre seul je
l'ai déjà vécu mourir seul plus jamais
voilà Gad Elmaleh quel est le Malet au
Casino de Paris du 14 mai au 16 juin
pour 30 représentation
ultime exceptionnel et irez votre câble
voilà bien et j'accueille maintenant
Gérard Jugnot
bonsoir vous êtes ici pour votre 8e
long-métrage comme réalisateur comédien
monsieur Batignolles avec vous donc
comme acteur le petit Jules citruk
Michel Garcia qui est excellente
Jean-Paul Rouve qui est encore plus
excellent qui est vraiment une
révélation enfin dans ce film en tous
les cas et Alexia Portal voilà alors en
fait le personnage de Batignolles est
inspiré par votre grand-père même s'il a
pas vécu la même histoire disons qu'au
départ le point de départ c'est votre
grand-père Jo quand on écrivait avec
Philippe Lopez je disais tiens il y a
mon grand-père qui était bouché donc on
a fait un charcutier c'était plus rigolo
par rapport au petit garçon qui mange
pas de cochon et puis par rapport à mon
interrogation théologique fondamentale
qui est comment adieu peut interdire à
c'est assez créatures de ne pas manger
de rillettes
Jugnot vient dans cette émission on
parle de son grand-père
en 1951 dans le 19e à Paris votre
grand-père était bouché il a une
conduite héroïque pendant la guerre il a
refusé de faire du marché noir son
grand-père donc évidemment la libération
et les plus de clients puisqu'il est pas
de viande hein voilà quand vous dites
que vous êtes nostalgique des promenades
en brouette avec lui il vous promenait
vraiment dans une brouette
salut sinon il y a des trucs il
fouillent vous avez des enquêteurs non
mais c'est vrai c'est pas la campagne
c'est normal de se former dans des
boîtes
alors on a beaucoup changé tous les deux
c'est pas moi
c'était pas moi vous avez interviewé mon
cousin
et alors votre grand-père qui était
bouché qui a pas fait d'affaires pendant
la guerre sa femme ne lui reprochait
ouais c'est ce qui se passe dans le film
là la femme de Batignolles elle est
vachement contente elle est dans
l'appartement des Berne ça fait 200 m²
ils habitent dans une sous-pente
sociale et puis bon c'est vrai que les
Bernstein sont assez aisés et puis un
petit peu pris un peu méprisant mais
c'est aussi ça qui est intéressant c'est
pas parce que les gens sont victimes qui
sont zéro faute donc c'était marrant de
les situer comme Jean-Paul Rouve qui
fait Pierre-Jean l'amour qui est un rôle
de de de des grilles de rater de
d'écrivain raté il est même critique
raté comme le faire et donc
je sais pas ce que je voulais dire je
suis très fatigué
continue à en parler
c'est un film moi que je suis en train
de craquer là qu'est-ce qui se passe
Gérard c'est un problème de promo
après
j'aime ce film je voudrais qu'il marche
s'il vous plaît
pas l'avantage de suivre c'est qu'on
peut vous voir de nouveau avec la
moustache ça fait une paye quand vous
avez pas vu avec cette petite moustache
très différente 1930 très soigné toi
aussi tu veux revoir Gérard juni avec la
moustache appuie sur le 1 exactement va
voir Monsieur Batignolles le voilà en
images ah ouais c'est vrai c'est fausse
moustache histoire de moustache là on
parle souvent
plus de moustache pas de talent il y a
un truc que je savais pas que j'ai
appris en préparant cette interview
c'est qu'en fait vous avez été pendant
le service militaire au contres
espionnage mais ça je ne peux pas en
parler
je faisais partie de j'étais chauffeur
militaires à la DSM Direction de la
Sécurité militaire là où il y avait les
écoutes
moi j'ai un souvenir magnifique d'un
plan comme ça on aurait pu faire il y
avait les mecs qui étaient entre écoute
et puis il y avait à la télé Giscard qui
disait il n'y a pas d'écoute
j'étais en civil et comme j'étais en
civil j'ai mis la moustache pour passer
inaperçu et on faisait des filatures on
avait des 304 mais on filait des
Mercedes donc on allait pas loin quoi
c'était assez marrant comment tu m'as
déçu
et c'est le compte que ça fait couper
cette moustache pour quel film tandem
magnifique film aussi alors vous
remarquez qu'on n'a pas parlé de vos
parents ce soir j'ai d'habitude en face
jugno avec ses parents non mais il
raconte des conneries
ce soir pas d'histoire avec Odette et
André pas de conneries ce soir
avec l'accent peignoir alors qu'elle ne
l'a pas du tout
Français c'est comme les mecs qui me
disent Gad tu es marocains je dis ouais
[__] j'adore le couscous
de quoi tu me parles
moi moi je dis jamais Gérard et français
j'adore le camembert [__] non non moi
je suis parisien rive gauche le Parisien
de du Nord
alors donc on a pas parlé de vos parents
là pour le moment
on pourrait dire quand même une chose
non une petite chose autant Odette est
positive et même naïve un petit peu on
pourrait dire ça on s'en est vexé autant
André les rabat-joie non mais c'est vrai
il me dit un truc ta mère elle est comme
ça comme s'il avait passé 8 ans avec
c'est pas vrai vous la connaissez avec
Michel Drucker d'accord oui c'est Michel
qui me l'a dit
c'est Michel
bonsoir la promotion de Monsieur
Matignon avec Gérard Jugnot bienvenue
Gérard
Pascal Obispo Pascal Obispo Patrick
je vous dis ça plus simple voilà c'est
que vous êtes vous retournez votre fiche
voilà c'est ça vous êtes bien presby
c'est ça que je voulais savoir
non mais c'est écrit con et en plus
c'est mon côté génial Lepers
non mais vous êtes terriblement
pessimiste à cause de votre père
je savais que je suis un peu attiré vers
le noir c'est pour ça que je fais des
conneries et du rire pour que t'attirer
vers le noir
un souci comme toi je suis sûr tous les
comics vous avez dit par exemple
l'humour c'est comme les essuie-glaces
dans la pluie du malheur ouais ça
n'arrête pas la pluie mais ça permet
d'avancer
moi je trouve ça assez joli il y en a
une autre aussi qui est très très belle
dans ma vie j'ai fait deux phrases
l'autre dis donc la deuxième j'ai fait
ça à l'autre c'est vrai l'autre c'est la
vie c'est comme une boule de flipper
il faut faire durer c'est Corinne Charby
il faut faire durer la boule le plus
longtemps possible mais on termine dans
le trou oui mais je pense que Guy Béart
l'a dit aussi
vous allez avoir droit à une interview
de jugement dernier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça fait peur Gérard Jugnot
as-tu volé de l'argent dans le
porte-monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais
petit jamais jamais
ça c'est une chose Gérard Jugnot
as-tu enfermé des élèves de sexe féminin
dans les cabinets de l'école
malheureusement non
Gérard Jugnot
têtu tripoter dans les chiottes du lycée
avec des copains oh ça m'est arrivé oui
je peux rien laisser moi Gérard Jugnot
tu vas rentrer au Paradis si tu te
repends à l'époque dans les chiottes du
lycée avec tes copains y a-t-il eu
pénétration
ne dis pas je ne mange pas de ce malade
si je peux me permettre
Gérard Jugnot
pendant tes vacances à Royan
tu masturbé en pensant à Annette
sans doute oui à mort à mort
Gérard
regrette tu d'avoir été aussi lourd dans
ce club de vacances en Tunisie pour
obtenir de cette malheureuse ta première
pénétration
je me souviens pas
je me souviens pas mon père
regrettes-tu d'avoir été aussi lourd
pour obtenir cette malheureux j'ai pas
été lourd j'étais léger
Gérard Jugnot
tu as fumé ton premier pétard aux USA
avec clavier et l'ermite
souhaites-tu la même chose pour ton fils
Arthur c'était pas le premier mais c'est
quasiment le dernier parce que j'ai eu
des hallucinations
c'était très fort c'est parce qu'il y
avait là-dedans j'ai vu des mecs avec
des canoniers sortis des taillis et j'ai
hurlé
Gérard Jugnot
tu n'aimes pas les hallucinations non
non tu as tort
genre
profitez de ta notoriété pour séduire
pas assez
mais j'avais des sosies qui s'en
servaient à ma place
as-tu déjà profité de ta notoriété pour
demander aux femmes des choses contre
nature
c'est pas osé mais ça aurait dû
c'est un peu tard
Jugnot
une migraine pour échapper aux devoirs
conjugales
non
Gérard Jugnot as-tu déjà fait l'amour
sans réel désir de procréer
tout le temps
Gérard Jugnot
as-tu déjà trompé ta maîtresse
non
mercredi dans un cinéma
alors voilà on va commencer avec un
petit email de rime qui habite en
Tunisie et qui me dit j'ai 21 ans je
suis tunisienne j'adore ton émission ça
serait bien si vous invitiez Djamel
Debbouze il est là
Jamel
[Applaudissements]
allô
que j'ai trouvé par terre dans une rue
américaine qui s'appelle
pourquoi elle est pas bien ma veste
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
émission j'ai l'impression que ma veste
a jeté un [__] de froid si vous voulez
je peux mettre un autre truc si ça vous
dérangement
comme ça depuis 1964
parce que dehors il se passe des trucs
incroyable
tu sais qu'on a gagné la Coupe du Monde
nous hein
c'est c'est le style c'est le style de
state ah d'accord oui c'est à la mode en
ce moment elle est bien cette veste
vous êtes pas jeune vous êtes des vieux
dans votre tête je m'en [__] il y a
des trucs incroyables qui se passent là
dans les rues
il faut que vous faut il faut sortir
dans les magasins
c'est le surplus du cirque Barnum
c'est pas un magasin
ça fait plaisir parce que j'avais pas
quoi dire à un moment donné tu es sauvé
par balade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à McDo
ça donne envie de se faire livrer une
quatre fromages
[Applaudissements]
si allons-y
bonjour salut c'est cool je me présente
je m'appelle Kévin
je ne sais pas quoi on avait dit toi
c'est bon les gens quand j'étais petit
me disaient ça va bien jouer
tu commences pas à toi sinon je vais le
dire au producteur là
vas-y s'il te plaît regardez là-bas elle
avait que d'habillage braquage les mecs
d'alliage oh les toupie hein bonjour
vous reconnaissez tiens Bernard noir
une vie un chien un doute
ça va bien
ça va bien très bien c'est très bien
décoré très bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Michel comment s'appelle alors cette
magnifique machine très compliqué ça
s'appelle la barre la barre de phare
mais la barre de fer quoi la barre de
faire tout la barre de faire des
exercices la barre de faire des
[Applaudissements]
arrête tu me saoules là
Monsieur et Madame Karembeu ont un fils
comment il s'appelle comment il
s'appelle
6 x 7 parce que c'est possible
bonjour vous vous reconnaissez Jean-Paul
Gaultier
mon oreille de la Chambre ne serait-ce
donc pas dégazuivement de demoiselle qui
prend viennent du bol de la colline là
ou quoi mais oui bon tu te lombardes que
votre vision est juste et assez herbe
il est vraiment mon valet mais l'amour a
ses raisons que les limites ne
connaissent pas les vraies raisons de
son amour
[Musique]
ça va ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon nom est bon James Bond et je
travaille au service de la reine
Élisabeth 4 plus de menteurs
de Pizza Pino
le très très bien de Jamel Debbouze en
cassette et en DVD pour les riches
mesdames messieurs énormes
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir
[Musique]
et tu t'éclates parce que tu as tu as un
dessin un destin incroyable maintenant
tu chantes avec Barry White comment on
dit chez moi
ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai qu'une seule envie quand on me
demande de pas bouger cette bouger je
trouve
interview croyance
est-ce que vous croyez que les drogues
douces conduisent forcément aux drogues
dures
ou au montant rouge
non pas du tout
est-ce que vous croyez qu'elle Alain
Chabat peut sauver Canal+ bien
évidemment sans problème à la super à la
Chabat à la Chama peut sauver n'importe
qui
peut sauver canal comme il peut comme il
peut trouver des solutions
est-ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
bien évidemment que non
alors là ça n'existe pas pour ma part si
je n'ai pas de sentiments je ne peux pas
prolifer
donc vous croyez à l'amour sans sexe
j'ai pas dit tu as fait ça mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'il manque il peut y avoir
une forme d'amour qui n'est pas palpable
t'as jamais pécho sans avoir un petit
sentiment moi jamais de la vie ça serait
se [__] de la gueule de ma partenaire
et ça c'est pas possible il faut qu'il y
a quand même un respect mutuel et rester
passe par l'amour bravo
est-ce que vous croyez Jamel Debbouze au
pouvoir surnaturel alors vous pouvez
venir pendant mon interview comme vous
voulez vous apparemment je crois qu'il a
un petit sentiment pour toi Amélie
est-ce que vous croyez au pouvoir
surnaturel de Goldorak bien sûr j'ai des
preuves
tu sais Goldorak il existe et Actarus
avec de mon quartier
bien sûr là
est-ce que vous croyez Jamel Debbouze
elle est fait des crèmes anti-rides
je me prononcerai pas le sujet est trop
délicat le sujet
d'accord clinique prouvé dans les
laboratoires
qui depuis des années mettent des crèmes
antirides et simplement
ça marche pas très bien en tout cas
est-ce que vous croyez que Patrick Fiori
peut à nouveau rencontrer le grand amour
après sa séparation avec Lara Fabian je
me demande comment il a fait pour le
rencontrer une première fois
mais tout est possible après tout est-ce
que vous croyez que l'homme a vraiment
marché sur la Lune ou que c'était une
manipulation des studios d'Hollywood
c'est chez franchement je me pose encore
la question on en parle souvent avec mes
parents
là c'est vrai c'est bizarre quand tu
regardes bien moi je peux pas m'y
retourner les mecs
incroyable et tout ils y retourne pas
donc peut-être c'était pas si incroyable
est-ce que croyez en vous bien sûr à
mort s'il y a bien une personne à qui je
crois c'est WAM
est-ce que vous croyez en moi
de plus en plus figurez-vous au début au
début je au début un peu après non
après j'ai dit non il va droit au mur
j'ai tant qu'il se changera pas il
pourra rien faire et puis là petit à
petit figurez-vous qu'un peu ça me fait
plaisir ça fait non mais c'est vrai en
plus je regarde les émissions que je
regarde à la télévision
très très meilleur de Jamel sur Canal+
en DVD et en cassette mesdames messieurs
achetez-le
dans ma vie
ça va alors maintenant je devais
accueillir monsieur Xavier Couture qui
va être sans doute le nouveau président
de canal jusqu'à ce matin 9h il nous a
dit qu'il venait dans l'émission Ce soir
et puis il a fait appelé par sa
secrétaire pour dire qu'il venait pas
donc ça promet voilà un mec qui tient
parole mais je vais quand même faire
l'interview
c'est un garçon fiable je vais quand
même faire l'interview Laurent si vous
voulez faire Xavier Couture
bonsoir donc sauf scénario à la chaise
c'est vous qui vous retrouverez donc la
semaine prochaine à la tête de Canal+ on
va en parler
jusqu'à jusqu'au début de la semaine
vous étiez directeur d'antenne directeur
des sports Directeur des Opérations
Spéciales de TF1 vous avez 50 ans après
les études de médecine de sociologie
vous êtes rentrés comme responsable des
relations publiques chez Thierry Sabine
ensuite l'équipe le sport un quotidien
qui était un énorme échec et qui vous a
retrouvé ruiné
mon pauvre Xavier
enfin bon les gens qui s'étaient abonnés
à l'époque ne trouvait pas ça lamentable
bien au contraire ça il y avait une
vraie place à l'époque pour un journal
de ce type et j'en avais eu l'idée avec
quelques collaborateurs qui étaient
moins pas au même niveau que moi et je
pense qu'on pourrait ressortir cette
idée c'est pas très bien il fait bien
couture
donc à l'issue de ça vous êtes ruiné
vous entrez à TF1 en 1988 ensuite c'est
un passage éclair à la 5 de Berlusconi
le Groupe Export je découvre
et vous revenez à TF1 en 1993 exactement
donc vous êtes marié en comment vous
savez tout ça Thierry c'est
les enfants les enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est magnifique merci donc vous êtes
marié Xavier Couture en deuxième noce à
Claire Chazal passionné de golf fan de
BD on dit que vous êtes un gros gros
flambeur au poker c'est vrai j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup le poker oui
c'est vrai bien c'est vrai alors publié
chez grassez votre premier roman qui
s'appelle coma vous savez comment on
fait Xavier
de ouf pour essayer
donc vous voulez que je fasse le pitch
oui
simplement
quand on lit on voit que c'est vous qui
l'avez écrit quand même j'ai pas eu de
gens donc voilà le narrateur s'appelle
Mathieu il est peintre homosexuel et il
est fils de Sophie Kléber qui est une
actrice de renommée internationale en
Sophie Kléber Sophie Marceau bien sûr
vous avez changé
tout commence par la une magazine qui
s'appelle primo un magazine à scandale
qui sort le lundi matin et quand Sophie
Kléber voit la une de ce magazine primo
elle reconnaît son mari
et son fils enlacé dans une position
sans équivoque aucune la phrase exacte
est sans équivoque aucune voilà
donc elle voit son fils
j'aimerais bien qu'on s'y est exactement
elle voit son fils Mathieu donc avec son
beau-père évidemment enlacé et en voyant
ça
tellement décontenancé que elle est
fauchée par un autobus et vous dites
d'ailleurs tu ne les plus belles phrases
du livre ça peut être violent un autobus
si vous voulez
pas mal bien sûr parce que il y a
plusieurs il y a plusieurs degrés de
lecture et je crois que c'est ça aussi
l'école de la vie quand on voit à
l'autobus à l'arrêt on ne se rend pas
compte
voilà donc elle est fauchée par
l'autobus parce que c'est violent en
autobus si elle tombe dans le coma et
pour se venger Matthieu le fils de
Sophie Kléber donc va se castrer le
rédacteur en chef de Primo comment vous
parlons pour obtenir une confession
écrite de la part de ce rédacteur en
chef sur les méthodes de la presse
scandale voilà mais tout va déraper la
vengeance tourner au drame face à un
livre très violent oui oui très violent
Thierry oui bien sûr mais il y a une
scène où ah oui il y a une chanson
c'est très très violent vous parlez de
l'anatomie de l'abjection contemporaine
c'est une belle phrase qu'un pote à moi
m'a vendu je l'ai replacé je l'aime bien
cette phrase je pense qu'elle résume
bien la situation elle est à peu
prétentieuse ce qui est à mon image et
pourquoi pas littéraire et je la
revendique cette phrase j'aime beaucoup
alors ce qui vous a conduit à écrire ce
livre Xavier c'est d'avoir fait
l'expérience d'être un people livré
c'est pas paradis voilà les aventures je
voulais appeler ça les aventures de
Mario les people et puis je me suis dit
non coma coma c'est bien emblématique de
la chaîne pour laquelle j'ai travaillé
il y a encore peu de temps et non c'est
un bon titre déconne pas ils vont te
prendre un canal comme PDG c'est mieux
que lui bien mais alors Xavier
sérieusement en épousant le cler-chose
vous saviez bien que vous seriez livré
au paparazzi oui mais oui le but premier
n'était pas de l'épouser le but premier
de la pécho ah ben c'est comme je me
suis fait
un peu voler j'étais obligé de réparer
comme on disait au 19e siècle voilà
parce que vous avez fait un mariage sur
médiatisé avec le Tout-Paris alors c'est
très marrant parce que vous avez renâclé
à poser devant l'église il a fallu vous
supplier pour vous acceptiez de faire
des photos devant l'église mais
contrairement à signer en fait les
photos près de l'hôtel devant derrière
l'hôtel était vendu à Paris Match et on
les a vu dans Paris Match la semaine
suivante vous aviez oui mais ça c'était
pour échappé à d'autres paparazzi quoi
vous savez ce qu'il faut il faut livrer
un peu il faut se livrer à un journal
pour éviter
alors quand Claire Chazal publie son
deuxième roman vous êtes une serrée
ulcé
pour une imbécile alors qu'elle a fait
HEC vous dites mais bien sûr
bien sûr elle est extrêmement brillante
je n'aurais pas épousé une imbécile les
gens qui me connaissent le savent bien
sûr alors il y a autre chose qui vous
insulte aussi c'est la publication par
voici des confidences de votre première
femme
où elle raconte comment son mariage à
elle a été détruit par Claire Chazal ça
vous a bien énervé ça aussi Xavier non
mais oui c'est la vie privée on n'a pas
le droit on a pas le droit d'étaler ça
comme ça
voilà je crois que Claire Chazal est en
pour parler pour vendre notre
correspondance en ce moment d'ailleurs
et alors plutôt que de tabasser les gens
qui écrivaient des articles dans Voici
contre Claire Chazal comme bec BD ou des
articles sur votre vie privée comme
Jacques Colin est un ami maintenant qui
est devenu votre ami vous décidez
d'écrire un livre donc qui est ce livre
commun comment elle était accueillie par
la critique Xavier mais écoutez ce livre
a été plutôt bien accueilli par la
critique parce que au-delà du règlement
de compte il faut y voir une véritable
œuvre littéraire je ne découvre pas je
ne découvrais pas la littérature je suis
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de talents je
ne serai pas à la place que que j'occupe
je n'aurais pas cette place et je vous
ai pas assez de verre cette faconde et
puis c'est plus cette puissance
littéraire et et je pense que tu as un
livre qui restera vous savez il y a des
livres qui passent
et il y a des livres qui restent je
pense que mon livre
restera alors évidemment
Frédéric Beigbeder une fois plus c'est
montré très très critique à votre
endroit comme il l'avait été envers
Claire Chazal quand elle est publiée ses
bouquins c'est lui qui a remarqué cette
phrase un bus c'est violent c'est celui
qui l'a remarqué le premier il a
remarqué aussi que dans les trois
premières lignes et Xavier il y avait
deux fois le mot rester oui parce que
rester une fois c'est bien mais restez
deux fois c'est quand même on reste plus
quoi là il y a la force du verbe rester
quand on reste deux fois
erreur rester c'était pas joli non j'ai
préféré écrire deux fois reste mais vous
l'avez relu ce livre et bien oui je l'ai
relu ce livre et je l'ai trouvé
formidable c'était pas seulement libre à
clé c'est un livret mouvant c'est un
livre encore une fois très bien écrit
remarque quelques phrases comme tu
patauge mec tu patauge j'aime bien oui
vous savez la force des gens qui
répètent ça c'est enfonce le clou
beaucoup trop Gali qui patauge tu
patauge il faut qu'il reste il y a une
belle phrase dans le livre c'est les
malfrats sont souvent les premières
revendiquer la morale on revendique ce
qu'on a pas on pourrait vous l'appliquer
d'une certaine façon j'étais sûr que
vous alliez citer cette phrase la mettre
en erzorg c'est vrai qu'elle représente
assez bien ce que ce que j'ai accompli
dans mon travail c'est c'est ces
dernières années c'est vrai qu'on est
toujours le malfrat de l'autre et
quelque part je me suis embarqué dans
une phrase que je incapable de terminer
c'est l'argent pour laquelle je préfère
écrire parce que ça mérite de Xavier
honnêtement
ce que vous trouvez le plus amoral un
moral aussi la moutarde peut-être ce que
vous trouvez le plus amoral c'est le
c'est le fils qui couche avec le mari de
sa mère ou les paparazzi qui les
photographies c'est le paparazzi qui les
photographies qui est sale c'est lui qui
fait caca ou celui qui prend la photo
bien sûr vous défendez bien là mais bien
sûr mais comme marrant quand on a bossé
sur TF1 quand on a été directeur
d'antenne d'attaquer le voyeurisme parce
que TF1 c'est quand même la chaîne de
Star Academy
arthurisme
d'un jour rêve d'un jour pardon d'Arthur
aussi vis ma vie c'est comme cette
chaîne là non bien sûr mais comment
pouvez-vous attaquer le voyeurisme mais
parce que vous confondez voyeurisme et
et qualité et nous on a une mission on a
une mission artistique sur cette chaîne
et et il y a plusieurs degrés de lecture
une fois voilà ce que vous appelez vous
voyez au risque c'est quand même des des
émissions qui resteront des programmes
forts qui vont remarquer la décennie
alors bientôt il y a un nouveau
programme sur TF1 vous ne serez plus là
que Xavier évidemment c'est un petit
chêne Island ou donc on essaie de
détruire des couples c'est bon on
réfléchit beaucoup on a quand même on
fait des brainstormings on s'est dit une
île les gens ne peuvent pas s'enfuir
donc si on laisse des gens attention
c'est un panel de cette étudié on n'est
pas des personnes au hasard on il y a un
vrai casting c'est vraiment des [__]
oui oui les [__] mais pas que des [__]
il y a des gros cons il y a des racistes
quand même que le spectateurs
alors bon la critique a pas été tendre
avec vous Xavier il faut bien le dire
enfin on ne fait pas cette télé pour les
critiques je le rappelle mais pour les
gens qui regardent mais pour votre livre
pour votre livre la critique a pas été
très tendre avec vous non plus alors on
aurait pu compter sur le soutien de la
chaîne preuve d'avoir vous a invité dans
son émission qui s'appelle vol de nuit
parce que le passe au petit matin et
donc on vous a coupé au montage donc on
vous voit dans l'émission sourire comme
ça de temps en temps mais votre
interview a été coupé par la chariot ok
mon interview était saboté
caviaret et je trouve ça scandaleux de
la part de PPDA qui se dit être un
journaliste intègre si vous voyez ce que
j'ai tiré sa meuf alors Monsieur alors
c'est ça alors c'est ça c'est réglement
de compte OK Corral je trouve ça
personnellement lamentable et ben arpivo
n'aurait jamais fait ça je tiens à le
dire voilà d'abord parce qu'il était en
direct voilà et que la meuf est très
jouable
vous avez
avez il choisit ses amis avec parcimonie
et moi en fait je n'en fais pas partie
voilà tout votre problème quoi je crois
non oui c'est vrai il est très difficile
de faire partie du sérail de Patrick
Leley qui est un être extrêmement
sensible bon après combien de fois dans
la conversation ce mec-là va être au
bord des larmes toujours et bon moi je
suis un petit peu trop dur pour lui un
truc trop euh voilà c'est ça alors on va
parler maintenant donc de TF1 et de
Canal+ interview vérité
[Applaudissements]
alors Xavier Couture d'après le journal
Le Monde vous n'aviez pas prévenu
Étienne Mougeotte donc j'y tiens des
plus proches collaborateurs de votre
nomination à la tête de Canal+ c'est
vrai oui c'est vrai mais vous savez ce
que c'est Thierry on a toujours
différents
Patrick le livre vous l'avez prévenu sur
son portable il était à l'aéroport il
partait à Moscou et vous l'appelez vous
lui dites voilà je m'en vais quoi c'est
pas un peu brutal mais non je ne savais
pas qu'il était à l'aéroport je ne
savais pas qu'il partait à Moscou en
plus j'ai une excuse c'est que j'ai mon
branlais complètement donc c'est vrai
mais est-ce que le lait est moujote
savait que depuis deux ans vous aviez
des discussions avec Jean-Marie Messier
d'abord pour remplacer Michel Denisot
ensuite pour prendre la direction du
pôle production c'est un petit métier je
crois que tout se sait et chacun
bénéficie des appels d'offres et chaque
année je pense qu'on est tous sur le
marché et que chacun a des connexions
avec les autres chaînes vous savez de
quoi on parle Thierry puisque vous-même
on vous voit régulièrement sur Teva ou
des fois et puis vous étions pour parler
avec la une aussi absolument c'est vrai
et voilà bien vous connaissez Pierre
Lescure oui je le connais oui oui un ami
à vous chez quelqu'un que j'apprécie
c'est quelqu'un qui qui sait partir la
tête haute sans stockshion et et je lui
dis bravo
est-ce que Jean-Marie Messine vous a pas
choisi un petit peu par défaut
finalement parce qu'on dit vous avez pas
la carrure du poste on dit beaucoup de
gens dans le métier disent c'est pas un
XXL quoi couture
non Jean-Marie de Messier mais
Jean-Marie Messier a besoin de résultats
il a des actionnaires qui demandent des
comptes et j'aimerais remercier a besoin
de de personnes qui savent faire rentrer
des sous dans la dans la caisse le
financier c'est pas trop votre domaine
on se souvient de du sport excusez-moi
d'en reparler mais enfin le quotidien le
sport qui était quand même un échec
financier grave et en artistique ça va
être très difficile pour vous Xavier
parce qu'on interne des gens comme
Farrugia chaba gattiaux vont sans doute
partir le personnel est remonté les
syndicats monsieur Cholet le responsable
de la CFDT a dit je promets à Xavier
Couture des jours difficiles
les gens d'extérieur aussi des gens
comme Jamel des gens comme decaune
beaucoup d'artistes vont pas vouloir
travailler pour vous vous allez gérer ça
comment bien on va gérer ça très bien
puisqu'on n'a pas besoin d'artistes sur
Canal+ puisqu'il n'y a pas d'artistique
et qu'on n'est pas concerné par
l'artistique on a simplement des
annonceurs on va faire rentrer donc des
des recettes on va mettre beaucoup
d'écran et on va mettre des films et du
foot je ne vois pas où est la place de
l'artistique là-dedans puisque le film
qu'on achète il a déjà été
et travailler par des artistes d'accord
oui c'est vous êtes vachement
intelligent bah c'est logique enfin il
faudra être con pour pas comprendre ça
j'ai commencé
alors bien sûr vous allez tenter de
rassurer tout le monde Xavier c'est
normal le milieu du cinéma en leur
promettant vous continuerez à leur
donner ce que Canal+ leur donne chaque
année bien sûr même si Messier veut la
fin de l'exception culturelle française
il l'a dit rassuré de [__] tout le
monde toujours dans l'ordre vous pouvez
pas arriver en étant tout le monde
est-ce que Jean-Marie Messier Xavier
vous n'aurez pas engagé pour faire le
seul boulot finalement pour virer tout
le monde on a dit ça de Brignais aussi
ensuite de beaucoup de personnes je
crois que le sale boulot est beaucoup
été fait à Canal et à part deux
techniciens de surface il reste plus
grand au monde à virer et maintenant
voilà le seul boulot a été fait vous
avez confiance en Jean-Marie Messier
bien sûr je peux faire que confiance à
quelqu'un qui m'a embauché et qui a eu
la finesse de sentir en moi la personne
idéale pour redresser la barre du bateau
Canal+ qui est en train de couler avec
des trublions comme Alain Chabat Jamel
enfin c'est
Dominique Farrugia non mais vous en
voulez plus de ces gens-là pour moi ces
gens-là méritent la fausse commune
que Jean-Marie Messier soit débarqué
je vous demande de vous arrêter
imaginez quand même c'est bon imaginez
Xavier que Jean-Marie Messier soit
débarqué mercredi et qu'il soit plus
patron de Vivendi Universal vous avez
quitté TF1 vous n'irez pas sur Canal
vous allez être comment un petit peu
Nick canicule ridicule je l'ai déjà été
donc j'assumerai vous savez ce sera pas
la première fois je serai ridicule et
voilà quoi au chômage et Xavier oui bien
sûr mais moi je suis un battant je pars
je pars battant moi donc je vais gagner
ce match bien sûr vous êtes courageux je
suis très courageux la preuve c'est que
vous êtes venu ici ce soir
ça s'appelle comment et c'est publié aux
éditions grassées mesdames messieurs
maintenant on place au blind test et
pour arbitrer le blind test j'appelle un
homme au dessus de tout soupçons mention
Philippe
j'adore j'adore j'adore
comment ça va bien ici je suis là je
suis là
il faut expliquer à Titeuf non il n'est
pas tout compris tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce qu'on gagne
qu'est-ce qu'on gagne d'abord
la blessure c'est très dur
attention
c'est très dur je crois que jamais on a
eu un blind test aussi
donc fallait trouver un truc vraiment
[Musique]
je vous demande de vous arrêter et oui
Francky Jordan
c'est très très dur mais vraiment Didier
bien alors là attention c'est très très
dur il est devenu peintre en bâtiment à
New York
[Applaudissements]
on continue Didier
[Musique]
bravo les soeurs bravo les
cinq six petits malgaches les sœurs
bravo bravo les surf
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter
je vous demande tais-toi
[Musique]
les trolls
les trolls ça s'appelle Wild Things
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reprise de Dylan morceau de Dylan
les beurres avec un y
très bien alors maintenant nous allons
entendre un groupe
ça tu dois savoir
attention
River c'est les
tomates
Lescure a donné la réponse est Talia si
vous avez triché
dommage dommage dommage
[Applaudissements]
je me demande de vous arrêter bien
[Musique]
non
c'est encore qui était
australien ah non c'est vrai bah oui
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maison n'a jamais raison
super banco qui a dit Michel page
[Applaudissements]
j'ai senti qu'elle savait j'ai tendu
l'oreille
et ne m'a rien dit elle a attendu le
silence elle a dit Michel faze
super super
c'est très important c'est du sucre
moi je le sais
oui bien sûr c'est mon fin de Man alors
quel est le score
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu